foreign
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today I just got
back from an 18-hour road trip from
Colorado to California Tad out of it but
this news dropped while I was on the
road why why was I in Colorado because
this guy was getting hitched that's
right thank you thank you everyone thank
you you could tone down the Applause now
thank you thank you all very much thank
you anyway John was obviously out there
he's one of the best men and uh he's
staying out in Colorado a little while
longer to enjoy himself to take in some
new sights and the rest of the team
mainly just koi is uh he's got himself
an ear infection and I think he needs to
rest a little bit longer so yeah just me
right now but what are we talking about
today we're talking about Dwayne Johnson
finally discussing the future of Black
Adam within the DC Universe James Gunn's
response to what Dwayne Johnson said and
the reason I want to talk about it is
because when I go online the main
rhetoric the main part of the
conversation surrounding Dwayne
Johnson's statement seems to be
something that I am just not in sync
with is from the first time I read it to
every time I reread it I have not
thought this which is Dwayne Johnson got
the boot he's no longer going to be
Black Adam that's not what I interpreted
as I feel like it's laid out right here
in his statement but and so I just want
to go over it I got a little bit more of
a positive take here and maybe I'm
talking out of my ass and I'm being
overly optimistic but I just feel like I
I'm being just logical about it I don't
know I don't mean that as an insult to
to other people it just that's just my
interpretation of what's being set here
so let's go into it now um there's kind
of like a two-parter uh to Dwayne
Johnson's uh statement that was released
I just want to focus on the first part
of it because that's where the good
stuff is and he says my passionate
friends I wanted to give you a long way
to Black Adam update regarding the
character's future and the new DC
Universe James Cox slapping James Gunn
and I connect it and Black Adam this is
very important I feel like this is the
part that's getting really
misinterpreted Black Adam will not be in
their first chapter of Storytelling
however DC and seven bucks which is Jane
uh no no Dwayne Johnson's company have
agreed to continue exploring the most
valuable ways Black Adam can be utilized
in future DC Multiverse chapters James
and I have known each other for years
and I've always rooted for each other to
succeed it's no different now and I will
always root for DC and Marvel and Marvel
I might not be Black Adam for a while so
you know if you want to cast me in one
of your projects I'm championing for you
to win and win big as well as DC that's
why I'm throwing your name in here in
this statement you guys know me and I
have very thick skin and you can always
count on me to be direct with my words
and I I find that to be true that he's
usually a very transparent guy that's
the word that keeps going around with
James Gunn as well that it's nice to see
the CEO even though I think he can be
very vague a lot of the time people keep
saying it's nice to have a transfer
parent CEO out there man just being
transparent with the fans so with the
words surrounding these guys is direct
with their words and being transparent I
feel like this message would have been a
lot more direct than he would have just
said I'm not Black Adam anymore the same
way Henry Cavill said I'm not Superman
anymore that's being direct with your
words and James Gunn he responded to
this what he basically just said was
something very short and simple which is
Love The Rock and I'm always excited to
see what he and seven bucks do next
can't wait to collaborate soon so with
all that being said what I got from this
was basically that whatever this
essentially phase one of James Gunn's
newly established DC Universe whatever
this phase one is of that Black Adam
will not be featured in that particular
phase but the Multiverse still exists
even a tweet uh that someone else asked
him recently saying are you open to
producing any else worlds DC projects
that aren't set in the DCU and he said
that is actively happening so with all
that being said and I didn't even need
that other tweet but because it says
right here that they want to figure out
how Black Adam can be utilized in future
DC Multiverse chapters so what I
gathered from this is that they're not
going to erase Black Adam they're not
going to even erase like the Snyder vs
movies or or anything that came prior to
before it what we're gonna do is focus
on a new timeline that new timeline will
be the main timeline that the audience
will give their time and Devotion to as
the essential core timeline but there
will be a Multiverse out there where the
other films perhaps exist within I don't
know what the ending of flashpoint's
gonna be but I imagine that's what's
going to help establish here and within
the multiverses you'll have things like
Joker you'll have things like the Batman
and then you'll also have things like
Black Adam and what they talked about
was yeah down the road as we're going
more into the else worlds we will have
Black Adam return it's pretty much laid
out right here it's just not going to be
in phase one so yeah we won't see Black
Adam for a while like Dwayne Johnson's
version of Black Adam at least but he's
not doesn't sound like he's going
anywhere to me you know Dwayne Johnson
is someone who has been championing for
so long for this character he loves
playing Black Adam he loves this movie
he is the only reason in my opinion why
this movie made any money at all whether
or not it actually profited is a whole
other question but the fact that people
watch it he was the main person behind
marketing this film his enthusiasm is
through the roof for it and I think he's
gonna do whatever it takes to make sure
he can still play him even if that means
just establishing him as part of the
Multiverse the thing that I just popped
into my mind that I'd be very curious
about is what was the conversation about
Henry Cavill like when Dwayne Johnson
you know Dwayne Johnson had to have
brought that up with his buddy James
Gunn like dude I spend so much time and
effort and going Toe to Toe with Warner
Brothers to get Henry Cavill to come
back and Superman and you pull this [ __ ]
come on dude we're supposed to be
friends you know there had to have been
some kind of you know I I don't know the
words animosity or some [ __ ] but that'd
be some kind of annoyance or grievance
towards the situation and I if there's
any part of the conversation I wish I
could have been a fly on the wall for it
would be that section right there
because Dwayne Johnson worked his ass
off to get Henry Cavill back and then
James Gunn gave him the boot and Henry
cavill's you know he seemed pretty
annoyed obviously so I'd be quite vexed
by the situation as well and I'm Vex for
Henry Cavill in that situation so I
would love to know what you know Dwayne
Johnson's interaction with him was about
like I can't imagine he's like I get it
man no no no totally no that's cool
we're cool because you know Dwayne
Johnson he really wanted that specific
film with Black Adam versus you know
Henry Cavill Superman but it got me
thinking you know you can't ruin
everything for us it can't they can't
take away all surprises for us it sounds
to me you know when he's going out there
James Gunn talking about how there's
going to be else worlds established and
Dwayne Johnson's reaffirming that saying
there's going to be DC Multiverse
chapters and black Cannon will be a part
of that what if down the road we
actually do get to at least have that
catharsis of getting Henry Cavill look
at this in the forever discussion we'll
carry-on with Henry Cavill what if we'd
end up actually getting that film where
Henry Cavill does show up for whatever
that Multiverse film is down the road
and you get at least have that fight
with Black Adam and Henry Cavill like
how cool would that be that after all
this time and getting the boot and
whatever that we do at least get to have
that one last time because it seems like
they're probably building to some kind
of crisis on infinite Earth or whatever
there's got to be something very special
down the road that they are building to
with a kind of multiversal crossover so
yeah I just basically wanted to hop in
here and say guys look they're
establishing that there's going to be
else worlds that it's not going to be
like the MCU where it's just one main
timeline that we're following even with
the fact that they have the Multiverse
there's very few projects within the
like you know the movies himself are
very they adhere kind of religiously to
the main timeline whereas like the other
stuff like things like werewolf by night
and whatever in the MCU they do seem
like they're part of the multiversal
side of it but they're a little bit not
as uh seen as important or as
significant to the development where
here to establish your new DC Universe
to kick it off that way with also
establishing that we're gonna have you
know the elseworlds simultaneously
running come on that's awesome like I I
think we'd probably get the main
timeline for a while first but you know
if you're keeping things like Joker
around or whatever you have to be
keeping the elseworld simultaneously
running so to me I think this is really
cool this sounds like a great Direction
and I think a way where both parties win
where James Gunn can do his main
timeline and the main things he wants to
do with it but that doesn't mean black
Adam's you know being exiled out of this
it sounds like Black Adam is still gonna
carry on in some way shape or form with
Dwayne Johnson in the role and that's
just my take on it based off of the
first the second paragraph here yeah
anyhow guys what do you think about this
piece of news leave your thoughts down
below do you think that this means
Dwayne Johnson's not coming back at all
what's your taking it are you excited
for the else worlds has all this
information regarding the shake-ups of
DC making you a little bit stressed out
and worried about the future comment
below thank you so much for being here
hey we'll catch you all soon
[Music]